[Music]
with warner brothers decision to
simultaneously release their 2021 slate
of films in theaters and on hbo max
there's lots to look forward to from the
comfort of your own home
from sci-fi spectacles to prestige
dramas and documentaries
here are the must-watch movies coming to
hbo max in 2021 and beyond
mortal kombat fans have been not so
patiently waiting for nearly 25 years
for another mortal kombat movie to be
released in theaters
video game movies have a track record of
being sub-par
immortal combat certainly has a part to
play in that history
not counting the direct-to-video release
of mortal kombat legend scorpion's
revenge in 2020
the last mortal kombat movie was the
poorly received
mortal kombat annihilation in 1997.
even as a sequel to the beloved 1995
original film
annihilation was enough of a failure to
completely end the mortal kombat film
franchise
until now ever since warner brothers
acquired midway games in 2009
fans have been anticipating a new mortal
kombat which is finally hitting theaters
and hbo max on april 23
2021
the movie is getting off on the right
foot by casting martial arts and stunt
professionals from across the globe
including louis tan and joe taslim and
along with actors such as makad brooks
jessica mcnamay josh lawson and hiroyoki
sonata
the cast is a good indicator that the
new mortal kombat is fully embracing the
fantasy franchise's martial arts
tournament roots
the trailers so far aren't showing too
much about the story
but if nothing else expect some
impressive stunts and
intricately choreographed hand-to-hand
fights
if you're a fan of dark modern day
westerns then keep your eyes on hbo max
those who wish me dead is based on the
novel of the same title
one written by michael corrita and
published in 2014
corrida is one of the credited
screenwriters on the project alongside
charles levitt and director taylor
sheridan
those who wish me dead stars angelina
jolie and nicholas hult in lead roles
along with tyler perry aidan gillen and
jon bernthal
filmed in new mexico the movie is
actually set in the wilderness of
montana
in a forest threatened by wildfires this
white knuckle thriller finds a teenage
murder witness being pursued by twin
assassins
needless to say that's not a great
situation to find yourself
in but at least this teen has the
assistance of a survival expert tasked
with protecting him
those who wish me dead is sure to be an
intense ride for its characters
while also being a commentary on the
state of the environment
the film is set to hit hbo max in
theaters on may 14
2021. the conjuring universe has grown a
lot since we were first introduced to
the world of the warrens in 2013.
since then we've met the likes of la
yona and valik
and we've run into that creepy annabelle
doll on more than one occasion
now we're returning to the main
storyline with the eighth film in the
franchise
the conjuring the devil made me do it
patrick wilson and vera farmiga are
returning as real-life paranormal
investigators and authors ed and
lorraine warren
originally scheduled for a september
2020 release
the devil made me do it was delayed due
to covet 19 and will now be out june 4th
2021
it's directed by relative newcomer
michael chavs who is best known to
conjuring fans as the director of the
curse of la yorona
the sixth film in the conjuring universe
the devil made me do it is based on the
trial of arnie cheyenne johnson
who was the first murder suspect to ever
claim demonic possession as a defense
the 1981 case also involved the
possession of an 11 year old boy
which is certain to be the source of
many scares in the upcoming conjuring
film
the devil made me do it hits hbo max
june 4th 2021
before hamilton in the heights was the
musical that put lin-manuel miranda on
the broadway map
featuring his characteristic pop-rap
style of songwriting
the story of his first show is much more
grounded than the bombastic historical
hit
a community in washington heights has to
deal with the sweltering heat of a new
york summer while working through issues
of family race and class
they're talking about kicking out all
the dreamers but every day is different
so
trying to make some noise the film
adaptation of in the heights is directed
by john
m chu and features one of hamilton's
youngest stars
anthony ramos in the lead role
originally scheduled to be released in
the summer of 2020
in the heights will finally release in
theaters and on hbo max on june 11
2021 for decades now fans have been
clamoring for a sequel to space jam
the 1996 looney tunes and michael jordan
crossover is still the highest grossing
basketball movie of all time
begging the question of why it's taken
so long for hollywood to make a new
installment
but in 2021 space jam a new legacy will
finally bring the space jam magic to a
new generation
this time the basketball star at the
center of the story is lebron james
trapped in a virtual reality space with
his son by a rogue gay eye played by don
cheadle james has to team up with the
looney tunes to beat a team of elite
basketball playing algorithms
directed by malcolm d lee and produced
by ryan coogler
space jam a new legacy is sure to be a
blast for families and kids
even if you're not a fan of bugs bunny
and company there will be something for
everyone in this wacky flick
as james's journey through virtual
reality will tie into other warner
brothers films such as casablanca and
mad max fury road
the game starts on july 16 2021
written and directed by guardians of the
galaxy director james gunn
the suicide squad serves as a soft
reboot of the 2016 film of nearly the
same name
while the 2021 film keeps margot robbie
as harley quinn
as well as joel kinnaman's rick flack
viola davis's amanda waller
and jai courtney's captain boomerang the
majority of the 2016 cast isn't
returning for the new film
instead the movie is opting for a fresh
start with new actors playing new
characters
the impressive and eclectic cast of the
suicide squad includes idris elba as
bloodsport
john cena as peacemaker sylvester
stallone as king shark
michael rooker as savant and pete
davidson is black guard
among a host of other actors a spin-off
show starring john cena's peacemaker
is already in the works and slated for
the 2022 hbo max lineup
between the cast and the adult tone
projected the suicide squad looks to be
a funny bombastic
alternative to the more serious side of
the dceu
and true to its name already promises a
high body count
we're all gonna die i hope so seeming to
follow in the chaotic footsteps of birds
of prey
the largely doomed team of the suicide
squad is coming to town on august 6 2021
reminiscence is an upcoming sci-fi
thriller starring hugh jackman
that looks to be channeling inception
which isn't all that surprising
considering reminiscence is a
collaboration between producer jonathan
nolan
and his wife director lisa joy who
previously co-created hbo's westworld
not much is known about the intriguing
film outside of its premise
jackman plays nick bannister an
ex-military man with certain
professional skills
for the right price he can offer the
chance for people to relive any memory
they desire when he falls in love with
may
played by rebecca ferguson things get
complicated when he gains access to her
memories and the truth about her dark
past starts to come to the surface
if you like action sci-fi or thrillers
reminiscence is a can't miss watch when
it comes to hbo max on september 3rd
2021
only a few months after a new conjuring
movie hits we get malignant and it's
sure to scare
our pants off aside from this being
conjuring universe creator james wants
first time directing a horror movie
since 2016's the conjuring 2 it also
features a face that might be familiar
to audiences who
absolutely love being terrified
annabelle wallace who is best known for
her role as mia in the first annabelle
film
has a starring role in malignant juan
has said that malignant isn't based on
any pre-existing movie or story it is a
completely original horror thriller but
beyond that
not a whole lot else is known it's
probably best that way too
there's nothing better to a horror fan
than a completely surprising and
terrifying movie-going experience
get ready for some major scares on
september 10th 2021
years after the ambiguous ending of the
sopranos fans of hbo's era defining mob
epic are finally getting invited back
into the life of tony soprano and his
family
only this time it's a prequel the many
saints of newark is a collaboration
between warner brothers and hbo films
that was originally scheduled for
theatrical release in september 2020.
like many of the warner brothers
features on this list the many saints of
newark was delayed exactly one year
and will hit a simultaneous release in
theaters and streaming on hbo max
this prequel to the acclaimed drama
series is set in the 1960s and 70s in
new jersey
pinned by soprano series creator david
chase the many saints of newark aims to
tell a story about the 1967 newark
riots the film will focus on the racial
tensions between the italian american
and african american communities of new
jersey
and the eastern seaboard the cast is
loaded with corey stoll as a young
junior soprano and james gandolfini's
son michael cast as a young tony
plus we've got vera farmiga as livia
soprano in addition to appearances from
jon bernthal
leslie odom jr and ray liotta sopranos
fans will have a lot to be thankful for
this fall when the gangsters make their
way to hbo max on september 24th 2021
denis vernal's take on dune is one of
the most hyped movies of 2021
following an entire year of being one of
the most hyped movies of 2020.
still the excitement persists with each
morsel of news that comes out
for sci-fi fans of many ages dune is a
fundamental work
a cornerstone of the genre and this
version looks to get a lot of things
right where david lynch's 1984 attempt
to adapt it failed
timothy chalamet takes the reign as dune
hero paul atreides
and oscar isaac will appear as his
father duke leto atreides
this will be the first entry in volnov's
two-part adaptation of the first novel
in the frank herbert series the rest of
the cast includes rebecca ferguson
javier bardem josh brolin zendaya
stellan skarsgard jason mamoa and dave
batista
so if you're ready to visit the world of
arakas just remember that fear is the
mind killer and that dune will be
hitting hbo
max on october 1st 2021
if you're a fan of films like hingham
high the outlaw josie wales or the good
the bad and the ugly
have we got some great news for you cry
macho is the next western from clint
eastwood it's based on the 1975 book of
the same name
written by n richard nash who co-wrote
the screenplay in the 90s with nick
shank prior to nash's death in the year
2000
and as you probably assumed eastwood is
not only showing up in front of the
camera but also sitting in the
director's seat
the film will be a neo-western meaning
it's set closer to the modern day than
the heyday of cowboys in the 1800s
still we're pretty sure the academy
award-winning director of unforgiven
will handle the century change
just fine eastwood stars as a washed up
rodeo star
and 20th century cowboy in 1978
he takes a job from an ex-boss to bring
the man's young son home and away from
his alcoholic mother
the film was shot in new mexico in
november and december of 2020.
if you're excited to see eastwood back
in the proverbial saddle
cry macho will ride onto hbo max on
october 22
2021 slated as one of hbo max's big
releases of the 2021 holiday season king
richard is setting itself up as an
awards season contender
the warner brothers biopic stars will
smith as richard williams
father of tennis superstars venus and
serena williams
the film is a look at their father's
influence and how richard coached them
to success
king richard features tsanaya sydney and
demi singleton as venus and serena
respectively
john bernthal tony goldwyn and dylan
mcdermott are also going to make
appearances in supporting roles
liev schreiber was originally cast but
was replaced by goldwyn in october of
2020.
not much else is known about the film
aside from its talent and premise
the script was pinned by zack bailen and
monsters and men director reynaldo
marcus green was brought on to helm the
project
anyone looking for more serious drama
fare on hbo max
is sure to perk their ears up when king
richard gets a release on the streaming
service later this year
especially will smith fans and tennis
aficionados
the match begins on november 19th 2021
it's been quite a long time since we've
seen a new project set in the world of
the matrix
the pivotal cyberpunk franchise has laid
dormant since the multiplayer role
playing game the matrix online
went offline in 2009 but over a decade
later
in nearly two decades since the last
movie lana wachowski is returning to
direct the fourth live-action matrix
movie
while the film doesn't yet have a title
resurrections has been heavily rumored
as a potential option
whoa although lily wachowski worked with
lana on the original matrix trilogy as
well as most of the sister's other
projects
she is not returning for this brand new
matrix film the production on the fourth
matrix movie was interrupted by the
covet 19 shutdown but it resumed filming
in the summer of 2020 and wrapped up in
november
of course no matter how fascinating the
world of the matrix is
a new matrix movie would be nothing
without neo thankfully
both keanu reeves and carrie anne moss
are returning to the series as neo and
trinity respectively
jaded pinkett smith daniel bernhardt and
lambert wilson will also be reprising
their roles from the matrix sequels
sadly lawrence fishburne has gone on the
record saying he wasn't asked to return
in his iconic role as morpheus
still the cast isn't without its fair
share of star power
yahya abdul mateen ii priyanka chopra
neil patrick harris and jonathan groff
will all be making appearances in the
newest movie when it releases on
december
22nd 2021. based on the jt rogers play
that took the world by storm in 2017
and wanted tony for best play oslo was
an upcoming film adaptation from
producers steven spielberg and mark
platt
rogers wrote the screenplay and the
adaptation is being directed by bartlett
shore who directed oslo on broadway and
earned a tony nomination for his work
with andrew scott of fleabag and ruth
wilson of the affair in the leading
roles this version of oslo is shaping up
to be the real deal
the plot of the film will tell the story
of the secret 1990s oslo peace accords
between israel and the palestinian
liberation organization
in other words it's a story about people
from wildly different backgrounds trying
to build relationships and the struggles
they face due to overwhelming political
turmoil and change
and since this film is based on an
award-winning play and backed by some
very successful producers
it's clear that hbo wants this project
to be a major hit
so while there's no release date for
oslo yet is likely to hit the streaming
service later in 2021
just in time for award season in the
same breath as the first of two
hbo film documentaries slated for
release on hbo max sometime in 2021
this one is hbo's expose on the covet 19
outbreak and how it specifically
affected china in the united states
in the same breath takes a look at the
government response from each country
and puts it in a wider global context
the documentary
premiered at sundance in january and
south by southwest online
in march to rave reviews it currently
holds an outrageously positive average
of 97
on rotten tomatoes a passion project for
chinese american director nan fu wong
in the same breath focuses on the
widespread governmental failures in
handling the pandemic response by taking
a deeper look at the two countries wong
has lived in
after receiving such a positive
reception following its festival
premiere
hopefully it will find its way onto hbo
max before the end of 2021
like the rest of hollywood hbo films is
camping at the bit to capitalize on the
game stop stock market anomaly that
occurred early in 2021
already hulu has released its
documentary gang stopped
and a number of other projects are in
the works from other studios
including an mgm film two netflix
projects and a feature documentary by
console wars director jonah tulis
however we're pretty sure that hbo's
documentary will be something special
given the studio's past track record for
creating critically acclaimed
documentaries
while the project is still in its
earliest stages andrew ross sorkin of
tbtf productions
lina motto of crash and salvage and
jason blum of blumhouse are all on board
to serve as executive producers for the
film
tv fans probably know sorkin best as
co-creator of the tv drama billions
it's an interesting mix of producers
that will hopefully result in a
fascinating expose
of one of the most interesting companies
of the year check out one of our newest
videos right here
plus even more looper videos about your
favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]